[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'était hyper intéressant de
partager
d'informer aussi et bien toutes les
personnes qui existaient des centres de
santé sexuelle qu'il y en avait 8 dans
les Yvelines et qui les personnes
pouvaient s'y rendre gratuitement en
plus de ça et que les jeunes aussi
pouvaient être informés
déculpabiliser
pouvoir parler
naturellement simplement
parce que j'ai compris là aujourd'hui et
que je n'étais vraiment pas du tout au
courant c'est que les jeunes en moyenne
d'âge dix ans tu es déjà avait déjà vu
un film pornographique là c'est quand
même 10 ans c'est très jeune et après ce
que ça en découle en fait ce que ça fait
par la suite ça ça se voit ça m'a un peu
interloqué quand même
[Musique]
lorsqu'on est au collège au lycée c'est
bien tout de suite aller voir
l'infirmière par exemple si on a un
souci parce que elle l'infirmière elle
sera déjà anonymement dire ben voilà va
voir telle personne ou telle médecin ou
voilà un centre de santé sexuelle par
exemple
voilà pour t'informer pour régler il y a
un problème s'il y a un problème parler
aussi la parole c'est hyper hyper
important quand on est jeune
[Musique]
les parents ont vraiment un rôle à jouer
dans l'éducation sexuelle de leurs
enfants par la parole comme on vient de
le dire par les informer alors c'est
vrai qu'on l'a dit aussi là il y a des
âges à respecter on va pas parler à un
enfant de la même façon lorsqu'il a 7
ans ou lorsqu'il a 15 ans et puis même
un peu plus âgé donc il faut adapter
c'est pas évident pour les parents
d'adapter la parole d'adapter les
conseils à son enfant mais je pense que
c'est hyper important d'ouvrir le
dialogue avec des mots simples et de se
faire aider
[Musique]